[Music]
I'm actually the guy that came up with
viola with the tire media virus in a
book I wrote 1994 and I look at viral
media and and weaponized mimetics is
kind of my problem child that I
originally saw it as the province of the
counterculture that that what we could
do is identify these sort of unresolved
issues in society and then nest in them
and provoke an immune response so that
whether it's you know racism or poverty
or corporate malfeasance all the kinds
of things that don't really get get on
the tube or don't really get discussed
in an appropriate way the only people
who ended up buying that book really
were marketers and like Russian
propagandists so they look at it and
they used these ideas not to promote
cultural growth or awareness but to just
provoke a response to sensationalize
anything by any means necessary
I mean and you know propagandists ended
up really good at this they look for
whatever issues are creating the most
tension in America and then how do we
how do we spread it so you know gun
control or abortion or you look for
things and what you do is really
operationalize conflict how do we get
people to look at those who disagree
with them as less than human and whether
you're a left blue state person or a red
right state person if you're watching
this I encourage you to think about how
is it that you think about those others
are you thinking about them as less than
you you probably are it's really hard
not to these days well they're not they
have similar fears they're just
expressing those fears in a different
way and if we can begin to see the other
not
as the way our weaponized memes are
encouraging us to but to see them as
humans well then it gets interesting
you know weaponized memes are the
clearest example of human beings
becoming the medium that we are no
longer the user we are being played so
we create algorithms to accomplish some
human goal something we want go out
online and find this you're my
intelligent agent you're gonna find
information and all that but we've
turned those algorithms against humans
and now what the algorithms are there to
do is to find what computer hackers used
to call exploits only you're not looking
for an exploit in a computer program or
an exploit on a server they're looking
for exploits in humans and where do you
find those exploits you find those
exploits in our painstakingly evolved
social mechanisms for connection so the
algorithms look for what is it that we
use to establish rapport what is it that
we use to to connect with another person
what are the what are the mechanisms
that provoke fear or self defensive
measures and the algorithms will not
knowingly but just because they're
trying everything they will eventually
find those and leverage them so the
algorithms on Facebook have found out
that people click when they see pictures
of their ex-lovers having fun if you see
a picture of your ex having fun you'll
click if you see your ex not having fun
you don't apparently but anything
positive about an ex so your feed is
gonna get those it even if you've
unsubscribed whatever to that person
those things are gonna slip in there
because they provoke use is it something
you need to see or want to see is it
good for you when you're trying to leave
that thing behind of course it's not but
it pulls you in and all the algorithms
want is to get you to do the behavior
that their programmers have asked
them too so we've spent and we're all
investing through our sp mutual funds we
are investing trillions of dollars in
companies that are developing algorithms
specifically designed to make us unhappy
to play us to abuse us and to to
compromise our humanity by leveraging
our our most important social instincts
for really isolating atomizing purposes
[Music]
you